you know for me there's something about
the filling-ness of an american pizza
style america pizza style that i love so
much yeah i get that like i love i
really really miss domino's pizza in the
uk it was so good i love that pizza
what's different about it in the uk
i don't know i don't know why it's so
good i i don't know either i think it's
just biased i think it just tastes the
same that's that's me
did you like i've had dominoes around
like lots of different places and they
all kind of taste so i i had little
caesars pizza in america right and i
thought it was delicious
the mini pizzas no the bigger ones are
the big ones like five dollar for like a
large right and everyone was saying like
bro it's like the worst pizza on earth
yeah i actually like like it i like oven
pizza it's not really great i had it i
liked it i liked it i'd much rather
dominoes than little i like little
caesars it was and also i'm just
convinced you don't have taste buds no
i'm like the the more the more you talk
the more i'm just like
also fine
my enjoyment of it also increases
knowing that for all of that for five
dollars that's insane
what that's the stuff
that's got nothing to do with the taste
the taste is good and it's only like
it's only heightened by the fact that
it's simply five dollars
for this massive like this could feed
the entire [ __ ] last supper this
little caesar pizza yeah because it's
not that good that doesn't affect the
taste i don't know it does it most come
on dude you go to a place right the
price affects the way you see the food
it does yes like when you get and that's
exactly why little caesars taste like a
five dollar pizza it's not that great
you get a dollar slice in new york yeah
it is foolish of me to act like knowing
it was one dollar didn't contribute to
my enjoyment of that yeah of course but
it was amazing you don't go to a new
york pizza place and be like i would
like an exquisite meal right now please
one dollar oh what a steal is it because
stone baked pizzas are not big enough
that that is one big factor is that it
yeah it's not okay so
so hypothetically if you found a
restaurant here in japan or wherever
that does stone-baked sourdough pizza
but it was the size of a new york pizza
but also they skimp out on the toppings
a lot right no i mean
in japan
but if you've had if you've had like
stone bait in england
like in europe and a lot of the time
they skimp out they're like i'm like you
don't put enough toppings on there's not
like there's like the sauce is generous
enough i'd save it like cheese like come
on man you know i i had stones in italy
and they stacked that [ __ ] because i
haven't i haven't been to italy but like
the best stone baked pizzas places i go
to they don't skimp out on the cheese
they don't skimp on the toppings because
you're in like a british british version
of it so they're like they fix it
like they don't want to the one i had in
northern italy was packed was it really
yeah it was like every time i've had one
in italy it's it's been like
like very lacking in toppings really
yeah and i think you're going to the
right places yeah i don't know like and
like as the person who is like the
biggest simp for bread like how does
that not play a factor in how these
pizzas taste so that's more of a i would
say stone baked in many aspects
in my mind it's more about enjoying the
bread than it is about the pizza like i
don't even consider it like right right
to a point where i'm like it's flavored
bread i'd rather just get like bread
like at this point you know just give me
the give me a real [ __ ] pizza bro if
it doesn't give me like five spots the
next day it isn't a pizza bro i want to
be [ __ ] up
[ __ ] me up with this pizza
you know what you know what the world's
right british people don't have taste no
i'm just like
i'm i'm team america with this one man
i'm american all the way on this one
from american pizza it goes hard it
doesn't it doesn't matter
there's a there's a time and a place for
an american pizza every time hands down
every day there is there is a time and a
place for american pizza but every day
it is not the superior
america i salute you with your pizza
okay then your pizza slaps keep doing it
okay let's see how okay then question
which one's better japanese sushi or
american sushi right
well no obviously like japan does it
better
well then
sushi yeah yeah so like would you if if
if i was to give you a choice of like
just standard like nikon of like just
regular tuna that you get like a cup
position here or california raw which
one would shoot but i feel like
comparing like i feel like at the end of
the day a pizza a stone baked pizza and
a pizza are like the same [ __ ] right
what you've said but like like
the a sushi roll is not even remotely
like sushi come on you cannot see me
dead in the eye
okay connor what you've basically said
yeah like is basically like oh yeah
sweet and sour chicken is the best
chinese food
you know orange chicken
orange orange chicken is the best
chicken tikka masala this is the best
indian curry in the world and i'm just
like no no i am not going to stand here
and listen to this [ __ ] okay i've
had okay right i've had both i'll become
an honorary italian for like a [ __ ]
day i don't care
your [ __ ] [ __ ] the rest of the
year
my italian fan base for this so be it
right you guys have [ __ ] pizza compared
to the americans come
on i just i just can't get over the fact
though let's trace it back to world war
ii
i you know i it's like with sushi and
stuff like that there's like a lot of
the like the sushi is not even close i
don't even think that's how is it all
close it's a same ingredient sushi no
it's not yeah a lot of the time the
ingredients aren't even similar
everything inside of a california roll
they use in regular sushi
just not together what's in the
california roll
califor what are the ingredients of
california
it's salmon is so confident it's salmon
cucumber yeah
well rolls into there's row but like
yeah but like roll rolls in general are
like an american difference yeah yeah so
different from super good because people
wouldn't say stone baked is that far off
but japan has roles as well
do they really yeah no but they don't
have the same kind of role not the same
kind of fried [ __ ] right no no no no no
no nothing like from what i've seen
japan japanese roles are just like one
fish in a row and i feel like that's it
yeah right this is a dumb argument but
i'm ready to die for it
okay that's trash taste there right yeah
okay it ain't a food
it's also without a food argument just i
just i'm watching a man commit suicide
and i'm just like all right connor you
jump off the cliff
don't don't say i didn't try to like
grab you and warn you that you're this
is a cliff you're jumping off i think a
lot of the viewers will agree with me
that american pizza is better than
italian first of all we have american
audience it's yeah and it's because i
guarantee that there are more americans
watching this than italians and there
are more people who have been to america
than italy
i've been to both
yes yes yes yes actually yes california
role is not japanese yeah we know yeah
we know that
what are the ingredients is it the
imitation crab
which they have
which they have you'll get crab on sushi
normally though really yeah of course
you do not that often i get all the time
really well i've never seen in any sushi
train you get like the crab head in the
thing but you never get like crap you
get a crab on it yeah you can really
you've never seen this yes the man who
just said that meat sushi didn't exist
even though he's had it so you know
to this day i still don't view it when i
go to get sushi no he's not exactly the
most reliable narrator
doesn't matter america pizza's better
than stone baked i'll die on the hill oh
my god this is just like uh the a bad
person making a good argument like
people just going to disagree with me
because i'm [ __ ] dumb it's not a good
argument it's a great argument it's not
a great argument
it's quite in fact the opposite you're a
good person with a [ __ ] this is the
preferential thing i just think the
pizza is better it's not flat-out being
i'm not saying okay look i'm not saying
american pizza is bad i love this this
is not what we are doing both pizzas are
fantastic right in their own unique
place like it is so far beyond belief to
even insist that american pizza could be
interpreted as better than stone baked
you mean like that's just a wild claim
it's not wild
people like american pizza more than
stone babies because they've never had
stone baked they have had stone bags
i don't know
how many people i think you'll be
shocked by the amount of viewers that
actually think america i want to set up
how many people how many of our viewers
who have had both can agree with you and
say that the americans your head your
head's in the cloud would you would you
say domino's is better than the stone
bay piece of them
in my mind i would rather domino's pizza
than stone baked pizza
and i have seen right i remember i
remember as well i thought i felt so
gratify like like hey i'll get this man
some taste buds i felt i felt so
relieved
which was who's that guy who's like 1500
netflix shows the uh i think he's a chef
from uh i think japan but he's he's
american the bearded guy yeah yeah i
forgot his name there was like one one
scene right where he was doing a whole
thing about pizza and he went around
reviewing all different types of pizza
and there was one time one scene where
he's like you know at the end of the day
though there's just something about a
domino's pizza that'll just go so hard
and i was like yes yes that's probably a
reason why we don't remember his name
pretending like domino's pizza or these
like fast-food pizzas tastes like [ __ ]
you're just clever i never said that we
never said we never said that it's it's
like it's like saying a mcdonald's
burger is better than like a gourmet
freshly made burger at a burger joint
you know like yes there's a place for it
but to to say that is better it's like
i've had many burgers where i would
prefer the mcdonald's burger over said
burger well yes of course because a lot
of the time they're just like yeah let's
just get some like good beef let's just
like not consider the ratios or anything
let's put like [ __ ] let's put like 500
no no what i'm saying what the argument
we're making is think of the best burger
you've ever had that wasn't mcdonald's
and put that next to a mcdonald's burger
which one would you like i've had a lot
of pizza uh in italy that wasn't stone
baked that i think was much better than
stone baked
there
it's like the heaviness of it yeah stone
baked isn't the only type of pizza but
to me definitely it is like the pinnacle
i i i [ __ ] i [ __ ] love stones
it's the best bread and you know what
it's because it's like the best bread
the best cheese used to come from a man
who can't appreciate the crust like this
comes from like i feel like you've
already tasted the pizza it's because
[ __ ] tastes like because i don't eat the
crust that i can appreciate a [ __ ]
good stone break because it's the only
pizza that i eat the crust okay you have
like it's like watching a vegan eat a
chicken wing it's like oh my god there's
a monument it must be a really [ __ ]
good chicken you don't even appreciate
bread so how can you even have an
opinion on what's better pizza like you
know what i mean like you don't have a
core function no no no it's it's like i
don't appreciate ninety percent of bread
because to me ninety percent of bread
taste the [ __ ] same you know that's
but it's like when i i'm after i don't
have to get you to stop writing you
cannot say i was on your side until you
said that that's like that's like me
going bro every [ __ ] rice and noodle
is the [ __ ] same yeah like it's like
that's just yeah udon is exactly the
same
it's like no different from instant
noodles both ninety percent's the same
okay it's like ninety percent of the
ramen nudes i didn't think you could be
racist towards white people but in that
moment i think you genuinely were i
think that was actually racist towards
white people bro
french people clutching their baguettes
right now french bro germans are losing
it right now that's half of german food
man dude
we gotta do a trash taste special we
just take gaunt to a german bakery and
he just is like what the [ __ ] i didn't
know you could have 15 different types
are you saying okay yeah are you saying
that a pretzel tastes the same as a
baguette
it's pretzel bread oh what's going on
this is bread
not the little [ __ ] hard like
cookie-esque ones like like bristles a
pretzel yeah all right i'm gonna be
honest okay how are you about to say i'm
gonna be
honest a pretzel to me is just a salted
paquette
that's what that's what it tastes like
to me
right that's that's kind of what it
tastes like to me okay
like to me to me bread
okay to me like to me i can't i can't
eat this that's how world war three
began
to me i can't eat bread by itself a lot
of times it needs to be flavored okay it
needs to have some butter on it like for
example a baguette i need some butter
with that baguette a lot of the times
okay pretzels they have salt okay
no you can't just eat a baguette like a
good baguette with butter no just just a
bigger just eat a bite i can't [ __ ]
eat baguette by itself
that's just like you've just lost all
your weight
this episode's gone you like won the
italians and then threw them away
what the [ __ ] god
even the attacker
even the italians are doing this right
now you're going to european tour
because like a [ __ ] actor
okay with the cross you know with the
crust you're not eating you know it's
not like you have the pizza part with
the cheese and you know and the toppings
and everything and then you have the
crust part right that's a very small
ratio to the whole pizza itself i can't
eat a pizza sized crust no matter how
good like the [ __ ] stone bait crosses
i can just chow down on the whole
baguette like strawberry when it's when
it's good quality like i don't know
principle as well like if it's if it's
lightly salted it's oh don't even don't
even need it i don't think you've had
good bread gone genuine yeah i think you
if you if you had fresh bread like good
bread i think you'd change your favorite
fresh bread is good but like like not
like [ __ ] tesco bread no no no no no
i've i've had fresh bread but bread to
me it's like fresh bread i'm i'm
skeptical now where have you had this
fresh bread okay so you you got you
you had fresh bread yesterday no that
was that was [ __ ] great could i eat
more than just the slice that we got no
that was that was too much and with the
slice you know i i [ __ ] i got to
destroy that whole plate i could not i
could yeah
that's like every time i go to an
italian restaurant
i've had many meals which i've enjoyed
the bread like an amount where honestly
if the rest of my food didn't come out i
would be happy every time i go to an
italian restaurant in america and they
always give you that like the plate of
bread i'm just like more i need more
this is not gonna be enough bread to me
is a starter it is a starter it is not
the meal you can't just have bread as a
meal this man would not i don't know who
i'm offending with this take right now
but to me like the entire middle ages i
i can't have peasants
i kind of have like pure bread as a meal
i'm pretty sure like if you were born in
the 1700s in europe you would be so dead
i didn't think we're gonna have enough
for dinner
what the [ __ ]
i feel like right
you guys made me such a big [ __ ] deal
about this pizza thing that i didn't
think was a big deal
and this man walks in here being like
bread is [ __ ] okay okay like straight up
like what like you don't even have like
a gluten allergy or something or
something [ __ ] like that to like behind
but i didn't say bread was [ __ ] i said
bread is not a meal you said 90 of bread
and i quote taste the same okay
okay i'm gonna go back on that statement
okay
ninety percent of spread does not taste
the same how much then huh how much
percent but i mean like 87.
with bread i can't have bread as a meal
that's like having pure rice as a meal
okay no
as an asian i can't just have of rice as
a meal i know people can just have rice
as a meal but you need some stuff you
need some [ __ ] seasoning on the rice
you know you need some flavoring you
need something to go with the rice i can
have rice as a meal yeah i know you can
but i know i know you can but red red
bread doesn't feel the same like roll as
rice right it literally does no it does
literally no it doesn't it doesn't yeah
i mean like i i'll i'll completely
disagree that all bread tastes the same
or whatever but i can agree that all
rice tastes the same yes okay i i would
i would say most right really yeah
really
that is that is there is different types
of rice oh yeah but yeah like obviously
i can tell the difference between like
japanese rice and like saffron but it's
like rice pudding and all that [ __ ] as
well it's all nonsense
i mean is rice pudding even rice said
that that's the point comparing the
roles that bread and rice phil is like
no it's completely different it's
totally different i can't believe you
you're japanese joey you're going to say
that all rice tastes the same where a
huge part of japanese cuisine is like
the subtle differences in how the rice
tastes hey yo that's all [ __ ]
or anything and you get like the massive
meal and they bring out the [ __ ] bowl
of rice
this is the this is the top branded rice
of this prefecture and i take a bite i'm
like bro this tastes like you are wrong
it does not taste like it tastes exactly
the same
you're you're chowing down on it too
[ __ ] fast to appreciate the subtle
[ __ ] taste it's really just carbs
it's just that's what bread is that's
what bread is literally just calves it's
literally just carbs it's so much more
than that whereas rice is just pure
starch right bread has so much more that
goes into making a good bread right
you've got all the different ingredients
anymore right rice is just like 100
starch right no because there is subtle
differences into how to cook rice
but no no but like if if someone if if
we brought out two bowls of rice right
and one was from like [ __ ] you know
october prefecture
i could not tell you the [ __ ] no it's
not just about the type of rice it's how
you cook it as well which is why you
know sushi rice tastes different
depending on which sushi place you go to
because sushi rice tastes different
because it's got vinegar in it no but
that it's cooked with vinegar it's
seasoned with vinegar yeah obviously
yeah so it's part of the cooking process
but if it's right if two if there was
two bowls of sushi rice one from akhtar
and one from nagano you can't tell the
difference that's like saying if two
pieces of bread were cooked exactly the
same then they you know then they taste
the same which they would because they
cooked exactly the same way
that's
i feel like both of these arguments are
[ __ ] stupid yeah they are i just i
just realized both arguments here i just
realized
i'm losing my mind to this [ __ ]
conversation now
i i think i i do agree though rice is
less uh what's the word diverse diverse
than bread like the bread has
way too many i'm saying but like my core
argument is that i can't eat bread as a
meal it's the same way that's the same
way as eating riceism i genuinely
believe you haven't had good bread like
genuinely i have had good i don't think
you have was the bread we had yesterday
good that was even compared to german
bread that's mid
was that was it good bread yesterday i
thought it was kind of good it was good
it was good it was good right don't get
me wrong it was good bread but i'm
telling you man i i've been doing it
i've never been to germany i don't know
like yeah i spent a lot of a lot of my
childhood in germany and i can tell you
man it's [ __ ] good it's so good like
every time i go to german restaurant
it's like amazing because it's like the
only thing that germany does well right
is the three foods that german like
specialize in beer which is food there
it's not a drink it's a food uh you have
bread and then you have meat like just
the meat is good right sausages right
right yeah [ __ ] amazing right great
sausages and there's a reason why they
stick to three things because they
[ __ ] do it amazing the bread is
insane everyone's like french baguettes
no french baguettes can like [ __ ]
themselves bro german bread is like 20
000 light years ahead right of it it's
it's not even comparable so could you
what if you could have bread as a meal
why why don't you then just say you're
on variation right you want like
different things like if you just have
bread every day yeah you'll get bored
but i can easily have bread occasionally
as a full meal if i needed to really if
i if it was german bread yeah no qualms
about it yeah of course german brother
like a fresh pretzel yeah if you give me
like three brittles just by itself not
like no no mustard or anything give me a
beer too give me a beer with that oh i
need i need a stronger taste than just
bread
anything i have had a good yeah
no matter how good the bread is i can't
eat a bread as an entire body we're
going to do you know we're going to
germany
germany get a good break i can
appreciate good breads you know i can
appreciate a good slice before the
actual meal comes out before before the
actual serving of whatever dish i've
ordered comes out you know bread is a
good starter gets you know gets the
palette going but can i eat an entire if
i go to a restaurant and i'm like you're
lucky
not a german job i'll tell you that
waiter uh i would like to order an
entire plate of bread and nothing else
i'm just like no i i can't do that
that's why you're the bakery don't go to
the restaurant yeah that's what amazing
there's something called a bakery that
serves exclusively
i want to try this [ __ ] dude